welcome to bananamores dan levy and
natasha legero
are here to double team you with
friendship and funnies and that's
what i call jokes you know call me
old-fashioned
hello drew barrymore and friends i'm dan
and i'm natasha and we're the hosts of
house hunters comedians on couches
unfiltered on discovery plus
which actually takes longer to say than
it does to produce an entire season
we actually shot two episodes just while
we were waiting to log on to the zoom
what's crazy though is even though we
made 18 episodes of the show
this is the first time natasha and i've
actually been in the same space and i
got to say natasha
you got shorter oh well dan you somehow
got more jewish
whoa you cannot say that kind of stuff
anymore you have to be woke
at all times i know and i'm very woke
i mean i have a twitter and my husband's
been to a protest
so don't talk to me about woke you're a
millennial look at you
look we are the point is
we love all things real estate and
before we even had the show
we would just send each other red food
links like all the time i'm in escrow on
three properties right now i mean i
don't even want them i just love
docusign
see some ladies love their etsy and
pinterest and natasha
loves her docusign pro we are obsessed
with everything hgtv i mean i like every
single show i come home at night and i'm
like i need a fix and i'd better be
fixer-upper
but house hunters is my favorite every
spin-off
every single one but it's hard including
ours ours are the best
but it's hard to relate to that show if
you live in any big city in america
because every episode is just
unrelatable it's like dan and tasha are
looking for a 25 bedroom house
with 20 hundred bathrooms a pool a
tennis court a tennis court in the pool
and their budget is five dollars i mean
you can't even buy salmon at whole foods
with the amount of money these people
have for a down payment
you can't even buy a mango at trader
joe's
a more realistic thing is dana natasha
are looking for a
one-bedroom condo in west hollywood they
need constant citizen app updates with
murders
they need neighbors who never sleep in
spread coven and of course there's no
parking their budget
two million dollars and they miss out
because they were all cash offers
damn you cryptocurrency thank you so
much
[Applause]
oh that's funny dan levy and natasha
legero
everyone wow i love them what a set